foreign
what's the most important Century in
human history
some might argue it's a period of
extensive military campaigning like
Alexander the greats in the 300s BCE
which reshaped political and cultural
borders
others might cite the emergence of a
major religion such as Islam in the 7th
Century which codified and spread values
across such borders
or perhaps it's the industrial
revolution of the 1700s that transformed
Global Commerce and redefined Humanities
relationship with labor whatever the
answer it seems like any Century vying
for that top spot is it a moment of
great change
when the actions of our ancestors
shifted Humanity's trajectory for
centuries to come so if this is our
metric is it possible that right now
this century is the most important one
yet
the 21st century has already proven to
be a period of Rapid technological
growth phones and computers have
accelerated the pace of life and were
likely on the cusp of developing new
transformative Technologies like
Advanced artificial intelligence that
could entirely change the way people
live
whoever meanwhile many Technologies we
already have contribute to Humanity's
unprecedented levels of existential risk
that's the risk of our species going
extinct or experiencing some kind of
disaster that permanently limits
Humanity's ability to grow and thrive
the invention of the atomic bomb marked
a major rise in existential risk
and since then we've only increased the
odds against us
it's profoundly difficult to estimate
the odds of an existential collapse
occurring this Century very rough
guesses put the risk of existential
catastrophe due to nuclear winter and
climate change at around 0.1 percent
with the odds of a pandemic causing the
same kind of collapse at a frightening
three percent given that any of these
disasters could mean the end of Life as
we know it these aren't exactly small
figures and it's possible this Century
could see the rise of new technologies
that introduce more existential risks
AI experts have a wide range of
estimates regarding when artificial
general intelligence will emerge but
according to some surveys many believe
it could happen this century
currently we have relatively narrow
forms of artificial intelligence which
are designed to do specific tasks like
play chess or recognize faces
even narrow AIS that do creative work
are limited to their singular specialty
but artificial general intelligences or
agis would be able to adapt to and
perform any number of tasks
quickly outpacing their human
counterparts
there are a huge variety of guesses
about what AGI could look like
and what it would mean for Humanity to
share the Earth with another sentient
entity
agis might help us achieve our goals
they might regard us as inconsequential
or they might see us as an obstacle to
swiftly remove so in terms of
existential risk it's imperative the
values of this new technology align with
our own this is an incredibly difficult
philosophical and engineering challenge
that will require a lot of delicate
thoughtful work
yet even if we succeed AGI could still
lead to another complicated outcome
let's imagine an AGI emerges with deep
respect for human life and a desire to
solve all Humanity's troubles
but to avoid becoming misaligned it's
been developed to be incredibly rigid
about its beliefs if these machines
became the dominant power on Earth their
strict values might become hegemonic
locking Humanity into one ideology that
would be incredibly resistant to change
history has taught us that no matter how
enlightened the civilization thinks they
are they are rarely up to the moral
standards of later generations and this
kind of value lock-in could permanently
distort or constrain Humanity's moral
growth
there's a ton of uncertainty around AGI
and it's profoundly difficult to predict
how any existential risks will play out
over the next Century it's also possible
that new more pressing concerns might
render these risks moot but even if we
can't definitively say that ours is the
most important Century it still seems
like the decisions we make might have a
major impact on Humanity's future
so maybe we should all live like the
future depends on us because actually it
just might
[Music]
to learn more about how emerging
Technologies may affect our future and
what role you play in defining that
future click here
foreign
[Music]